bonsoir à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans le journal de tv 78
voici les titres de ce jeudi 25 février
avec la pandémie mondiale on pouvait
croire que les créations d'entreprises
seraient à l'arrêt ce n'est pas le cas
en 2020 dans les ive et une 21000
entrepreneurs ont lancé leur société
témoignage de l'un d'eux pour en parler
avec nous également notre invité benoît
mal à signer conseiller formateur à bg e
yvelines un réseau d'accompagnement de
créateurs d'entreprise également des
commune yvelinoise qui n'avait plus de
caserne de gendarmerie font revenir les
militaires quelques jours par semaine
des permanences ont été mises en place
exemple à follainville dennemont
enfin le portrait d'un métier presque
oublier celui darche taille et il ne
reste que 70 en france dont 1 dans les
yvelines
rencontre avec sergio championnat à
maisons laffitte
juste avant cela une nouvelle nuit de
violences dans les yvelines hier soir
aux mureaux à poissy à maurepas la
celle-saint-cloud la verrière ou encore
à mantes la jolie
à chaque fois le même scénario ou
presque des projectiles et des mortiers
ont été tirés contre les forces de
l'ordre
au total six personnes entre 13 et 19
ans ont été appréhendés
nous ouvrons une page économique avec la
crise sanitaire certains entrepreneurs
tentent coûte que coûte l'aventuré de la
création d'entreprise des créations en
plein boom dans les yvelines en 2020
plus de 21000 sociétés ont été créées
juste avant d'accueillir notre invité
benoît mal à signer de vge yvelines en
écoute randy lucus à jeunes saint
quentinois qui est lancé sa société en
octobre dernier au micro de mélanie
poquet coussin meilleur aujourd'hui
c'est une société une agence digitale
nous accompagnons toutes les entreprises
et même les particuliers aussi dans leur
parcours numérique on a plusieurs pannes
dans mon service qu'on propose aux
entreprises et des paquebots création
d'identités visuelles jusqu'à la
conception du site internet ou même de
l'application mobile
[Musique]
j'ai un parcours assez atypique parce
que j'ai fait une formation stg gestion
spécialité sujet et après je voulais
continuer les études mais chercher
d'alternance et j'ai pas trouvé
d'alternance du coup je me suis dirigé
vers une formation donc le pitch and
putt et après ça je me suis dit ni vu
que les alternances est compliqué à voir
parce qu'il faut de l'expérience on va
se créer votre patience tout cela
j'ai lancé officieusement en janvier
2020 officiellement notamment parce que
la paperasse projettera je ne suis pas
content parce que l'amour des
professionnels c'est plutôt quand le
projet a été monté pour subventionner
pour être des partenaires comment dans
cette démarche et cette aventure pour la
formation de société pour l'argent je me
suis rapproché de cloud banques
tout est parti des fonds personnels et
pour continuer à parler de ce sujet nous
accueillons benoît mal à signer en
visioconférence avec nous bonsoir
bonsoir
alors vous être conseiller formateur au
sein de bg e yvelines c'est un réseau
d'accompagnement pour les créateurs
d'entreprise mais aussi les repreneurs
d'abord selon les chiffres de la chambre
de commerce et d'industrie versailles
yvelines 21 milles 130 sociétés ont été
créées dans le département en 2020
contre 20 1578 en 2019
on aurait pu s'attendre finalement à une
baisse conséquente mais finalement non
alors 6,4 pour cent d'augmentation
comment l'expliquez-vous feu alors c'est
vrai que sur les statistiques nationales
sur la création d'entreprise on a la
surprise je dirais d'avoir un effet
comme un effet vous les créations
d'entreprises sur 2020 ce qui surprend
puisqu'il peut surprendre du fait de la
situation pendant les explications
importante où j'en tremble un peu dans
le détail en exemple entre les lignes de
ses créations
c'est que beaucoup de ces entreprises
très grosse majorité je crois que c'est
à peu près trois quarts de cette vente
sont des entreprises individuelles au
régime entrepreneurs qu'une forme d
relativement simplifiée pour la créa à
la création et au fonctionnement de
l'entreprise et cette heure là pour le
coup ce boom des créations d'entreprises
en heure peut s'expliquer par une forte
demande notamment de l'activité
transport entreposage
le déplacement de livraison de livraison
de colis et de courrier et donc ça c'est
une notification liés aux à une demande
importante les activités qui se sont
développées sur des systèmes notamment
les restaurateurs qui font d'eux qu'ils
font là livré dans l'europe pas non plus
recevoir ils ont développé un service de
livraison de repas de commandes et
livraisons et donc ils ont eu besoin de
personnel pour pouvoir faire ce service
de livraison etc c'est une explication
importante et qu'il va falloir
surveiller j'irai à peu près puisque ce
qui va être important maintenant c'est
de voir un petit peu comment est ce que
c'est comment est ce que ces entreprises
nouvellement créés vont pouvoir durer
dans le temps
est ce qu'elles vont être pérenne ou non
alors du coup pour revenir un petit peu
aux chiffres de la chambre de commerce
et d'industrie en fonction de la période
de l'année on voit évidemment des
disparités en mars 2020 1610 création
mais en avril 2020 on tombe en dessous
la barre des 1000 avec seulement neuf
cent soixante trois sociétés c'est là
qu'on voit l'effet du premier
confinement aussi et donc de l'impact de
la crise sanitaire sur cette baisse de
création non mais je pense que si on
regarde sur aussi sur le sur l'ensemble
de l'année on retrouve après d'une
patience comme ça le plus important
donc effectivement certainement qu'avec
le premier confinement il ya quand même
eu un effet un effet beaucoup investir
que sur le chiffre est important en mars
il fut ton avril c'était aussi le
nouveau copain peu de données annonce du
confinement est donc le derrière ça
après ça les choses se sont mises en
place au niveau des des activités donc
notamment pour ce qui est de livraison à
domicile et donc l'activité après
reparti qu'enfin les créations
d'entreprises d'après sont repartis vous
l'avez évoqué avec évidemment là on va
dire l'augmentation énorme des
livraisons
les ventes sur internet il ya des
nouveaux profils de créateurs
d'entreprise mais est ce que il n'ya que
les livreurs qu'elle soit quel profil
finalement de ces personnes qui tentent
l'aventuré de la création
entreprenariale avec la livraison parce
que c'est une explication importante sur
le sur le volume 2 sur le volume des
créations d'entreprise assure sur 2020
maintenant le clairement une semble
quand même que globalement sur la
création d'entreprise ya pas on n'a pas
de profil type
on n'a pas de le créateur d'entreprise
qui n'est pas typiquement de tête classe
d'âge ou de telle catégorie sociale et
n'ont qu'à pas spécifiquement sur un
statut d'antan lorsque les choses sont
quand même très très mêlée même si après
de trouver un petit bout majoritaire et
revenir en fonction de l'activité
par exemple on prend l'exemple des
livreurs on est plutôt sur des personnes
qui sont étudiants ou juste après
l'étudiant est sur la bonne voie la
création de micro entrepreneurs c'est
une solution facile mais après au delà
de sable on a des fils extrêmement
variés tant dans le secteur d'activité
que dans la personne que que dans le
profil social n'est donc pas de profil
vraiment défini est ce que dans les
entreprises
comment heureusement bien bas profil
défier qu' il n'y a pas besoin d'avoir
spécifiquement tel type de profil ou de
voir évidemment mais du coup est ce que
dans les entreprises que vous avez
accompagné il ya des inquiétudes
particulières des créateurs d'entreprise
de 2020 donc c'est à dire vraiment
pendant la crise sanitaire que vous avez
pu constater des inquiétudes avant de
créer leur société les uns crient qu'ils
les inquiétudes pardon elles sont sur un
petit peu qu'est ce qui va se passer et
comment est-ce que comment est ce que ça
va durer quand est-ce que ça va finir
parce que les personnes qui ont démarré
leur activité jusque à peu près au
moment du film ans
mais confinement se sont trouvés très
vite confronté à un total de leurs
activités donc il a fallu à cela les
inquiétudes s'étaient surtout comment
avoir accès aux thèmes par exemple
toutes les mesures gouvernementales
régionales et c'est là qu'il y avait des
mises en place donc là c'était de la
quiétude a été tirée pas tant pour
maintien d'activités que pour pour avoir
accès à ces sites si on dit dans le le
il sera toujours temps je dirais une
fois que la crise sera passée de pouvoir
réfléchir aux à la relance et aux
eurobonds
et justement quel est un petit peu la
durée vie de ces entreprises qui se
créent pendant cette crise sanitaire est
ce que c'est des entreprises qui vont
comme vous le disiez peut-être comme
vous l'évoquez durer dans le temps est
ce que c'est viable
après la crise pour certaines et est-ce
que vous avez un petit peu voilà un
propre à un profil mais du moins est ce
que vous vous connaissez la durée de vie
ce que c'est des micro entreprises qui
vont disparaître après qu'elle ait un
peu la durée de vie espérant qu'elle
sera beaucoup plus long que la pandémie
ce qui est je pense que ça va beaucoup
dépendre de la capacité des de ces
entrepreneurs à qui veut dire à rebondir
à adapter leurs activités cirque eux et
ils ont créé une entreprise souvent sur
une opportunité qui était de exercé en
tant qu'indépendant là tout de suite
maintenant il va falloir que qui
appuient ce qu'ils arrivent à
transformer ces opportunités réellement
garant modèle d'entreprise et en modèle
économique cirque l'aïe
il ya eu un fait pareil si on prend
l'exemple livraison voilà est-ce que la
livraison de repas va se continuer parce
que malgré son rang pour évoquer oui
mais a aussi de télétravail qui s'est
développée pour quelques personnes qui
sont fait le travail peut être avoir
encore besoin de se faire livrer des
repas donc y est je pense que là c'est
un peu dans l'urgence qu'à une unité ont
créé l'entreprise système preneur c'est
facile en bas c'est facile des services
2000 des risques ils vont conduire alors
ça va être important que chacun puisse
véritablement se poser des questions sur
comment est ce que je peux maintenant
transformer ça vraiment vraie entreprise
avec avec un vrai modèle économique
dernière question rapidement sur les
défaillances d'entreprises en 2020 un
constat qu elles sont en baisse par
rapport aux autres années
est-ce qu'il faut justement relativiser
ce chiffre par rapport au dispositif de
soutien avec la crise si on pousse à le
relativiser exact ce serait très bien ce
serait une très bonne nouvelle donc ces
entreprises allant dans les faits
effectivement je pense qu'il faut quand
même relativiser dire attendre un petit
peu parce que effectivement il ya quand
même beaucoup d'entreprises qui ont
quant à elles qui ont j'irai tenu grâce
à une à une trésorerie qui était
maintenue et qui est maintenu à flot
avec les mesures gouvernementales
maintenant que le s que l'activité va
pouvoir se relancer
quand il va falloir faire établir les
états sur l'exercice comptable 2020 qui
va en rester et quels seront les
possibilités effectivement de rebond et
dans que je pense que ya beaucoup de ces
fermetures d'entreprises ou défaillances
d'entreprises qui peut-être
malheureusement n'ont été que le
retarder mais il faut suivre ça près sur
tout et être prêtes à les accompagner
pourquoi les accompagnent et maintenant
qu'elles sont on va sortir de la crise
quand on sortira la crise peut avoir est
là pour pouvoir les accompagner à leur
bon quel rebond merci benoît m'a signé
d'avoir été avec nous fun merci
dans le reste de l'actualité des
permanences de gendarmerie pour la
ruralité dans plusieurs communes
yvelinoise des bureaux ont été aménagés
pour accueillir quelques jours par
semaine les militaires c'est le cas à
follainville dennemont où les gendarmes
sont présents chaque mercredi après midi
à proximité du marché
les précisions d'astrid bergère sur les
images de nicolas landry depuis un mois
et demi à follainville dennemont dans le
nord des yvelines les gendarmes sont
présents le mercredi après midi au
moment du marché dans un local prêté par
la mairie ils reçoivent les habitants on
accueille les plantes
lorsqu'il ya des dépôts le tente on
renseigne les personnes nasri à des
questions puis lorsque c'est un peu
calme on en profite pour faire une
patrouille au contact de la population
sur le même sur le marché des valeurs
locales accessible aux personnes à
mobilité réduite une banderole
gendarmerie nationale a été installé
cette initiative permet de rapprocher
les militaires et la population la
philosophie d'amour c'est également de
réinstaller dans la journée à mendier
dans cette fonction qui m'est très chère
de service public
on est véritablement un service à la
disposition du public alors suivant
l'angle répressif quand évidemment il
faut l'être mais également on doit être
là me sens utile en appui en conseil en
bien veillance pour écouter les gens
cette présence permet aux personnes non
véhicule et d'avoir un poste de
gendarmerie plus proche que celui de
limay à 5 km elle rassure et crée aussi
du lien social
on remarque avec nos anciens une grande
solitude
toutes nos activités habituelles
ne peuvent pas se dérouler il y avait
beaucoup d'inquiétudes de la part des de
nos aînés et voilà le fait de pouvoir
exprimer leurs difficultés qu'ont
rencontrées
or cette proximité c'est très important
des autres communes aux alentours profit
du même dispositif
adro pourrait fontenay saint père un
premier bilan sera établi courant avril
avec à terme l'objectif de l'étendre
c'est un métier presque disparu que nous
vous présentons à présent celui d'art
chaudier il n'en reste plus que 70 en
france pourtant cents archers difficile
de jouer du violon ou du violoncelle
sergio sont qui à part dont achetiez
professionnel a ouvert les portes de son
atelier à maisons laffitte à celje gars
de son godet il a pas mal des musiciens
qui pensent qu'elle archers c'est un
accessoire mais sans marcher le violon
c'est tout petit guide à qui serait donc
un violet sont sont archi sérgio
chantier à 41 ans exerce les métiers
d'art chantier depuis 80
il fabrique entretien et restaure des
archers pour les violons violoncelles
altos et contrebasse parfois il a de
travail décentes retient de l'entretien
des changes les mèches par exemple des
restaurations et ça aussi je le fais les
matins et après je mets quand je me
focalise à la construction ils entourent
réalisé plus de 125 archer un produit
coûte entre 3000 et 4000 euros
les musiciens en commandent leurs
archers sur mesure pour en construire un
sérgio chante ya passe environ 30 heures
dessus
un travail minutieux et qui nécessite
beaucoup de patience ça c'est un blanche
de par la boucle d ici je coupe tout à
la main j'obtiens
ça remonte larcher se compose de quatre
parties la baguette la hausse le bouton
et l'écran avec beaucoup de matériaux
différents comme le nacre l'argent les
bennes ou encore le crin de cheval
autant de matières qu'il faut savoir
travailler par exemple la courbure de la
baguette il avec un brassard goulet et
il ya des parents qui manquent à l'appel
comme ça et ce avant différents jeux
qu'en fait c'est nous c'est stable sait
plus qui sortent plus aucune école
n'existe pour devenir archetier sérgio
chantier assez fort mais lui au sein de
l'atelier raffin à paris depuis août
2001 le quadragénaire s'est installé à
son compte à maisons laffitte
ils cherchent maintenant à acquérir une
boutique pour davantage de visibilité
autre portrait enfin cette fois ci celui
d'un golf celui de saint germain en laye
un club au passé prestigieux qui a vu de
grandes compétitions organisées sur ses
terres plusieurs personnalités ont
également tapé quelques balles sur son
grimm reportage de michael et demi
d'euros il fêtera son 100e anniversaire
dans un an le golf le saint germain est
implanté dans la forêt depuis 1922 sur
d'anciennes terres agricoles le parcours
a été dessiné par l'un des meilleurs
architectes de l'époque harry colts le
britannique inconscient un parcours
forestier reconnu dans le monde entier
avec notamment 116 bon coeur saint
germain a considéré suivant suivant leur
autre employé le mot anglais banking
parmi les dix plus beaux parcours de
l'europe continentale pour certains dans
les cinq parcours d'europe continentale
mais c'est sûrement le parcours le
le le plus célèbre le plus ancien
résident lui le parcours évinois
organisé neuf open de france dont le
dernier en 1985 avec la victoire de
severiano ballesteros les greens ont en
plus accueilli la légende béluga le
célèbre golfeur au 64 victoires sur le
tour américain
les personnalités prestigieuses sont
également venus à saint jean d'angély à
partir de 1945 saint germain et l état
major de l'armée américaine
et nous avons reçu ici notamment le
général eisenhower le général d'iter
mais surtout le général than à voir nous
avons aussi reçu ici le duc de windsor
qui venait régulièrement jouer au golf
de la propriété qu'il avait en bordure
du bois de boulogne
aujourd'hui le golf associatif reçoit
régulièrement des professionnels ils
organisent des tournois et notamment des
championnats de france la structure
compte près de mille adeptes le plus
jeune à trois ans et le plus ancien 96
ans au delà de la compétition ce club
familial prône avant tout un style de
vie
être membre d'un club comme saint
germain c'est accepter le cdc des
tenants d'un club à la britannique c'est
à dire vivre comme ça pour son club
accepter les différentes compétitions
qui sont là et retrouver des amis et de
ne pas venir uniquement taper des balles
et repartira pas une partie pour
rejoindre ce club historique il faut
être parrainé par deux membres les
admissions lieu deux fois par
[Musique]
on
non
[Musique]
denis
c'est ici
[Musique]
il y est
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
l'avoir suivi demain votre émission
d'actualités et de loisirs rendez vous
avec le 7-8 week end et d'ici là je
souhaite une très belle soirée
[Musique]